your values as an organization need to
be woven
into everything that you do
[Music]
denise leon thank you so much for being
on my show how are you
i'm good thank you so much for having me
i am extremely excited to have you
brand leadership culture messaging
and best-selling author of fusion and
what great brands do
and you assist so many different
companies
on their brand leadership and messaging
and culture that i'm so excited to
sort of pick your brain in the next 20
minutes on
uh on what that even means can you tell
me a little bit about yourself and what
is branding in general yeah yeah well so
the number one thing you need to know
about me is that i love brands i've been
very passionate about brands not only as
a consumer or customer kind of you know
i have my favorite brands but as a
professional
i really tried to understand how brands
really engage people seduce people
invite
people into their community into their
world
and people both customers and employees
and other partners
and um so you asked me about the
definition of branding and i actually
frankly um don't use the term branding
because i think that you know
um you know if you think about where it
came where the term
came from it was when back when people
had cattle and ranches and they would
like
brand their cows with their logos so
that people would know that the cows
belong to them and
and that's really not what is necessary
or
appropriate or compelling in today's
course
we're not putting our logos on things
just so that people know
what you know who owns it or what who it
belongs to
what i consider to be brand building
this much more about
what you do and how you do it so really
becomes very much a part of
your business strategy and your
operations and to your point your
culture and your organization
so why is this even a topic that that
needs discussion
why why do so many people and companies
struggle with
exactly what you're talking about yeah
well i think a lot of companies still do
think about their branding and you know
so they think about
what should what should our name be what
should our logo look like what should
our web
website look like what should our colors
be and all things are important because
you know we are
um you know communicating and trying to
engage people through communications
but if you don't have the strategic
foundation of
what you stand for what your values are
how you're engaging your employees to
deliver
great customer experiences then and
what is your differentiation and all of
that then you really don't
have a brand um you don't have
something that is meaningful and
valuable and that really can
create um that that connection for you
talk to me a bit about your journey how
do you even get started with becoming
passionate about
about about this topic and helping
others then overcome it
yeah so i started my uh well i studied
like liberal arts background
in college i was a psychology political
science uh double major
and my first job out of school was in
marketing i was a
market research analyst and so um my
first
few jobs were really kind of
foundational a sense of you know
learning
in market research you know learning to
understand how consumers made decisions
and how companies could communicate with
them um
you know and to influence those
decisions i also did some product
management so
um really figuring out you know how do
you develop how do you research and
develop
products and how you bring them to
market and then i worked in an
advertising agency to really figure out
how do you create the creative
communications and the engagement with
customers
and out of all those experiences sony
electronics
recruited me and i ended up starting up
their first ever grand office
wow um and it was there at sony
that i really learned so much about the
value of
internal organizational alignment
and engagement um at the time this is
back
like in the 90s i'm definitely dating
myself but you know sony had just
started to kind of see
some chinks in the armor as apple was
rising and uh you know the thing about
apple is that you know their emotional
connection and their ability to
just create this this relationship with
our customers is so
powerful and sony definitely wanted to
compete on that but without the internal
understanding of how were we going to do
that what does sony really stand for
what do we really have to offer like you
know you we couldn't compete on speeds
and feeds anymore because
apple and other players definitely were
going out doing us on technology so
what was that emotional connection that
we create and
we internally within sony didn't have
one common understanding of that there
was no way we were going to be able to
deliver on that
externally but i learned a lot about
that at sony
and then for a variety of reasons which
i can tell you over a drink sometime
i end up resigning my job and starting
my own
kind of brand consulting consultancy
okay
consulting practice and did that for
quite a few years had some
opportunities to work on these great
brands that you were referring to
and then over time i've really shifted
from doing a lot of consulting
and a little bit of speaking writing to
doing mostly
speaking and writing and then just a
little bit of consulting
right so now getting getting this
message across and and helping others
understand engagement better and culture
and and brent
why is engagement difficult internally
within a company so i'm now asking as a
young entrepreneur as i go through my
journey of
hopefully building a company and
thinking about culture myself and
growing the team
i now get to be a part of a 270
person team in a hyper growth company
and
seeing the culture what are some
pitfalls that
that p that the leaders make when
they're trying to engage
their their both their consumers but
also their employees
and and then what are some important
things to keep in mind yeah
well actually a lot happens in that
journey that you just described because
i think that when you were small and
just starting up
you and your co-founders probably have a
really you know clear vision on what you
want to stand for and the kind of
company you want to go right
um but i think that often what happens
is
either a you kind of take that for
granted and as you
add more people you you kind of um just
assume that everyone gets it
and or b you get so consumed with
operations and development and really
trying to build a business
that those things overtake your desire
to create
this great organization and so you in
the scaling process
you lose that focus on
you know really what are we about and
really what are we creating
and so then you and you wake up one day
and like you say you have 200 employees
and you're like oh my gosh
you know and our culture sucks you know
and and you know we're competing in this
this brutal war for talent and we
are trying to offer an experience to our
employees
that may or may not be competitive um
and so i think that you really need to
um as a as a leader of your organization
as
you know one of the people who's driving
the growth you need to be
like very intensely focused on
prioritizing culture building
understand it doesn't just happen and
you need to be
not only talking about it all the time
to make sure that
you you're clear on you know the kind of
culture you want and the kind of
organization you want
but then also role modeling that culture
you know so
you can't just be all words it needs to
be action you know and then finally that
you are actually designing and running
your organization to cultivate that kind
of culture
so you know um which what groups of your
department uh
which departments or which groups in
your company need to be working together
better
or need to make sure you need to make
sure there's really tight alignment
integration
and make sure that you're cultivating
that in the way that you run the
organization you know
are there certain um employee
experiences or employee rituals or
artifacts or policies or procedures
all of these things you need to be
thinking about as you
put those in place to make sure that
they represent and really
support and advance your desired culture
so
culture building really is a strategic
leadership responsibility
that you as a founder or as an
entrepreneur need to be
you know accepting that responsibility
and championing
i think that's that's fascinating it's
you know i i heard you speak
at a few other occurrences and a lot of
the times you know it's this idea that
yeah we can put posters on the wall that
that scream our culture and our
messaging but then actions speak louder
than words right and and when i think
about brand and when i think about
you know what a company expresses i you
know people always think
outside of the company right what how
are outside consumers going to interact
with our products
but then i think people also forget and
i sometimes forget that
at the end it's the the people building
these products have to live by these
by these experiences and by these
messages right so that they can
develop the products that other people
will be happy about
what are some common themes that you're
seeing
with as startups are scaling with the
pitfalls that
leaders are making as they're losing out
of that culture is it simply that they
forget
or do other things come in the way yeah
well oftentimes they'll delegate it
to someone so you know again again as a
founder a leader you've got lots of
responsibilities and so you think okay i
can't i can't do everything
like hire good people to work for me and
certainly
you know you need to have strong goal to
execute
your strategies and to help you you know
implement your tactics
um but you can't as a leader ever kind
of
abdicate your responsibility for culture
building
and if you don't empower if you don't
give like let's say you have a head of
employee experience or a head of hr
if you don't give them the the tools
and investment and resources they need
to create this great employee experience
they're going to be you know hamstrung
and so their their effectiveness is very
much
tied to war buy into this so it's really
important for you
to make sure that you are continuing to
lead um the other things i think is to
understand that
um your values as an organization
need to be woven into everything that
you do again like you said they can't
just be words on a page but you need to
be applying them
especially to your people decisions who
to hire
who to fire you know who to promote who
to develop and you need to be using the
your values as a filter or as a screen
for your people not only because that'll
make sure that you have
the right people on the right positions
doing the right work
but that's also probably one of the most
important or most
influential ways that you share your
values with the organization
if someone sees you saying that you know
creativity and risk-taking is important
but
you are not but you are always um kind
of penalizing people when they fail
or you're actually firing people because
they failed or they're you know they
they took a risk and it didn't turn out
then people are going to be like well
wait a minute
that value that you were talking about
doesn't really seem to be a reality
really of course so you need to be kind
of thinking okay if if
this is the kind of value that i want to
have my organization
the best way to show that i mean what i
say is
in my decisions about people
100 and i think it also speaks to the
higher slow
fire fast right this idea that think
about the people that are in the company
they're not just
skillful people that are getting things
done but they're but every hire is going
to impact the culture and obviously the
higher up and the louder you go
the more critical it is what are some
incredible things that you've seen
people do in order to create good
engagement with their employees or
their customers outside some things that
i'm i might not even be
thinking of as i'm as i'm growing my own
company
um you know i get a lot of examples from
airbnb because i did a deep dive
into that organization when i wrote my
book fusion
and so um you know they created an
employee experience
department where they brought in all the
different functions that
impact an employee's a day-to-day
experience
and you know brought them together under
one person into one consolidated
group which meant that they were looking
at the employee experience kind of
the way that you look at a customer
experience like the journey that
employee has throughout their
their tenure and so they would um it's
they started their
their employee experience experience
during recruiting you know where
in addition to all of the functional
screens that someone has to go through
as a potential recruit you also are
interviewed twice
just based on values and that way the
company really gets
to know what your values are and gets to
assess whether there's alignment with
the company's values
and what's really interesting is a that
these values interviews
are not done by the hiring manager
they're done by
they're done by members of a committee
specifically designated towards values
interviews and
two um if they decide that this
candidate is not a fit like culturally
or is not aligned with values
they can actually overwrite the higher
override the hiring oh wow
this person could be you know absolutely
the right skills right
experience um the company's not gonna
hire them so i mean it's like having
very you know
prescriptive standards that enables a
company like airbnb
airbnb to attract the kind of people who
really believe in the mission
and who work by the values um and then
on the back side you know
um in recent months airbnb's had to lay
off a lot of employees yes
and the way that they've done so um
you know the letter from brian chesky
just the the humanity and the um
compassion and the empathy that was i
think demonstrated
through that is another kind of um
sign of how seriously the company takes
employee experience
and definitely 100 so you you made a
conscious decision yourself to
transition
your ex your experience from that of
building
the brand of a certain company and
culture of a certain company to now
looking in the broader picture about a
lot of different companies
so first of all i'd love to hear about
this transition and
why why are you so excited about the
work that you're doing now
yeah well you know um i i felt like i
could
have a lot more impact on a lot more
companies if i were to
you know kind of increase my speaking
business increase my writing and really
just kind of try to get my ideas out
more
um you know when you work for a single
company
or if when you do the kind of brand
consulting that i first was doing when i
first came out of sony
there's like deep dive into the
organization and so you can really
affect
change within that that one organization
right um
but i kind of felt like i i was limited
in a way and especially because
unlike maybe the folks who are listening
to this this interview
i wasn't going to grow a big company it
was just going to be me
i wasn't going to have any employees
instead you know the rate limiting
factor is
my bandwidth so i'm like okay if i want
to
impact the most people that i can um
it's going to have to be through
speaking and writing
and it turns out that i think when i did
a lot of self-examination about
what i got excited about and what i
found
life-giving um what i felt like i really
wanted to get better and better at like
it was a passion of mine to really hone
my skills at
it was speaking it was really kind of
getting out there in front of people and
figuring out how do i
what's in my head and all the research
experience that i've had
and be able to like communicate that in
a way to yes
that they understand that's just
fascinating to me and i can 100
so that's that's what gets me up every
day really i love it
about that challenge i love it so
alongside that messaging so
fusion what great brands do tell me a
little bit about each book and what i
can expect to find in there
and maybe one or two nuggets that we can
extrapolate from each
yeah yeah so what great brands do the
seven brand building principles that
separate the best
from the rest um now this book came out
in 2014
so some of the examples are a little bit
dated but i continue to hear from people
today of how
informative these seven principles are
because it really takes you through some
counter intuitive practices of brand
building like
um great brands avoid selling
products like they don't um you'll push
products on people promote features and
attack their technology
they're much more as i said earlier kind
of into this business of
producing people and drawing people and
making the emotional connection
and so my book shows you um how to do
that gives you some tools and frameworks
and then
lots of case studies and examples right
my second book fusion
how integrating brand and culture powers
the world's greatest companies
is about how you take your internal
organizational culture
and your external brand identity and
ensure that they are
mutually reinforcing and definitely
like integrated and aligned and
intertwined in such a way that you
really
you know are on the inside what you say
on the outside because then
not only do you engage your people
really effectively but you pass the
customer test of brand authenticity
because
these days customers want to know uh you
know
really what's behind the curtain and
they have the ability to find out
so you want to make sure that what how
you're operating your organization
really
is um with integrity and authenticity
so um i highly recommend those two books
and then i will say for your audience in
particular
i've written a small book called um or
it's a paper really a change this
manifesto
about minimum viable brand it's all
kind of based on the minimum viable
product but it says you know
given that you're going to have limited
resources limited time
when you're first starting out what are
the few things that you need to make
sure
that you have in place as you're
building your brand
and so all of these things can be found
on my website and you know hopefully
they'll be good resources for your folks
100 i think i think everything you
talked about is just fascinating i think
that today especially knowing in 2020
and we've seen especially this year how
important company culture is
both in terms of adapting to layoffs and
a lot of the a lot of
stuff that's been coming out over the
over recent years in company culture
is i think things that people in my
years of studying and
people in my age group that are starting
companies we're very very conscious of
and we're always thinking okay from day
zero
how do we get the right culture and just
the other day my good friend who's
uh just finished the stanford business
school he asked me
and michael what is going to be your
schtick as a ceo i'm going to be the
nature ceo and that's the culture that i
want to bring in my
building my company and you know so the
thinking of people are thinking of
what types of of the niche markets they
like to address and what type of
cultures and communities they want to
build i think that's that's amazing
i know that in the company that i'm with
now hippo insurance the culture is
incredible
and and i'm really i'm fascinated to sit
next to the ceo when i get to
and talk to him about the way that he
addresses these problems and
every on-boarding process is a new
adventure and a new celebration
by over 200 people which is just
incredible
but denise before we leave i have to ask
the most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself yeah you know i'm like
well that's such a hard
question it's the hardest one and i
don't prepare enough so i'm sorry
i'm sorry as well yeah no so um i have
two and maybe the third one will come to
me
um so um definitely um
like achievement like driven okay so
i'll do with these driven i i am
definitely like someone who
sees a goal sets a goal goes after it
sure
i'm very disciplined in the sense that
um
i can like have like my way of doing
things my whole life is kind of arranged
in a way
so that i can achieve my goals and so um
those are the two you know the third one
i'm not sure
um i would say um maybe
uh this is more than one word but like
since i'm doing the d's
um like dedicated to my faith in the
sense that i'm a person of faith and i
really am guided by my faith
and so that provides the center and the
core for me
um so i could have cheated and used more
than one word on that last one but
hopefully that's perfectly fine
discipline dedicated to my day
denise thank you very very much this is
fascinating i can't wait to read these
books myself
it sounds like it's it's something that
seems incredibly insightful for for any
young entrepreneur or any leader
that wants to affect change in their own
community whether it's in a company or
whether it's in a simple community in
their family or whatever it is
it sounds like it's relevant for for a
lot of different things exactly besides
business
thank you very very much denise i really
appreciate it stay safe
bye